if you're hoping to pick up a plastic
bottle of water at one of the nation's
busiest airports you will soon be out of
luck
starting today San Francisco
International is rolling out a band to
end their sale at its shops restaurants
and vending machines it's part of the
airport's latest effort to become the
world's first zero waste Airport by 2021
John Blackstone is inside the airport
John good morning how exactly are they
implementing this band
well good morning well SFO says that
each person who comes true here produces
about half a pound of trash now try to
try to eliminate that waste the airport
has also cut back on the use of
single-use food items like napkins and
straws now they're going after these
single-use plastic bottles in favor of
reusable alternatives like this San
Francisco International Airport says
this could be the ticket to a greener
future for an airport that sells about
10,000 bottles of water per day
generates about 28 million pounds of
waste per year this is really a big
thing that we can impact in terms of
having waste not going into landfill
beginning today the airport will begin
gradually phasing out plastic water
bombs first they'll sell off what's
currently on store shelves
once that inventory dries up passengers
will be encouraged to refill their own
reusable containers at any of about a
hundred hydration stations or buy water
in glass or aluminum containers you're
trying to encourage people to do the
right thing
forcing them to do the right thing in
some ways we'd like to say encouraging
for the most part people seem to be on
board with the change if you know about
it it's it's great if you don't know
whether it's gonna be inconvenient but
that's headed in the right direction I
think you wouldn't buy a plastic bottle
of water the airport is following a 2014
ordinance banning the sale of plastic
water bottles on city-owned property
nationwide Americans discard more than
30 million tons of plastic every year
only about eight percent of it gets
recycled much of it ends up in landfills
where it can take up to a thousand years
to decompose
reaching toxins into our soil and water
but you'll still see plastic bottles at
SFO the ban does not apply to flavored
drinks like soda and juice want to do
some good and problem can't buy bottled
water in a plastic bottle you can buy a
soda in a plastic bottle yeah does that
make sense so that our hope is that the
industry continues to expand it there's
really not a lot of good alternatives
yet for teas juices and sodas but we're
hoping that changes over time as of now
the policy only applies at the airport
it doesn't apply to the airlines that
fly in and out of here SFO says it's the
first Airport to ban plastic water
bottles but it hopes the idea takes off
at other airports like that couple I'm
kind of puzzled why sodas and juices are
getting a pass here in white why water
is being singled out what's that about
what the airport says is that there are
already alternatives for water now that
we can get them in water can be
purchased here in aluminum containers
like this or even in boxes like this the
same alternatives don't apply to juices
and sodas at this time they're hoping
the industry will move in that direction
and of course lots of people now bring
their own reusable bottles and there's
lots of places to fill them up here at
the airport
baby steps I think it's good that
they're starting somewhere I think it'll
be inconvenient in the beginning but
it's such a sense such an important
message and it really is a line and you
see all the bottles that get from exact
yeah this is gonna be a continued
cultural flashpoint I mean the the the
Trump reelection campaign is selling
plastic straws which is a banned in some
places made hundreds of thousands of
dollars we could see a presidential
tweet on this subject before the day is
out all right I think so yeah all right
thanks to John Blackstone